est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu vas rien
mais je te quitte
ouais j'étais toute petite et ça m'a
marqué ça te va très bien j'ai grossi ah
non mais c'est très c'est très c'est
très
charm naissance au
printemps quoi un garçon une fille on
sait déjà il que tu les couilles à
l'échographie mais tu
préfèresarder la surprise je sens que ça
va vanner là ce soir hein c'est un super
bon sujet là pour vanner alors tu viens
pour un film le PO Chinel dans le
Carroir
ou là là ça va très ça commence très
fort ça commence très fort non il faut
dire que Judi est déjà la maman d'un
d'un petit Noé don don le papa est Danny
boun et l'année dernière après la
séparation vous aviez déclaré faire des
concessions des sacrifice c'est dans ma
nature mais on a beau se convaincre que
le monde ne tient qu'à une seule seule
personne c'est pas vrai voilà donc c'est
toujours des phrases aussi longues ouais
ouais des phrases très longues et en
fait pas du tout c'estàd que 1 an après
avoir dit ça vous êtes enceinte vous
avez vite changé la vie quand même hein
tout de suite enfin oui assez rapidement
assez rapidement bah oui ça sent très
bon ton savon hein c'est quoi non c'est
de l'UT de toilette ah ça Senton
ouais c'est ça sent jusque là ça sent
ouais moi j'ai une Dorat très développé
en ce moment làou ou c'est dû à quoi
c'est la c'est la grossesse qui éiste en
chien en fait ouais c'est ça ouais
sérieux sérieux j dit pour quelqu'un qui
avait dit euh voà on peut pas voilà plus
jamais ça d'une certaine façon on peut
pas on peut pas réduire le monde à une
seule personne pour quelqu'un qui avait
dit ça vous avez vite repiqué au truc
c'est tout ce que je veux dire non mais
on peut pas dire plus jamais ça et puis
il y a même des gens qui retombent
amoureux à 70 ans et ouais il faut
toujours croire à l'amour et au au
renouvellement à la Renaissance et et
voilà voilà mais ça pas mis longtemps
voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire quoi
non mais tant mieux pour vous hein il
dit que tu es pas farouche en bref quoi
non non non non pas du tout non non non
non
je dis que quand non je dis que quand on
a je dis pas ça je dis que quand on a
une nature je dis que quand on a une
nature amoureuse et féconde et féconde
on est rapidement amoureux et fécondé et
fécondé voàà c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire on est on est surtout
féconde parce que le corps sent que
c'est la à mon avis ouais la bonne
personne ouais ah c'est une personne
ouais d'accord c'est pas des paillettes
tu fais une VAN par minute une vanne
toutes les 2 minutes il y a pas de côté
à Canal c'était de Vannes par an c'est
il y a pas de règle faut dire qu'il y
avac gilaz qui te mettait la main aussi
ouais et parfois sa main me manque ouais
car il glissait parfois alors on a le
droit de dire que le papa c'est Maurice
bararteléi hein je crois que je crois
que toute façon oui c'est Maurice oui
tout le monde non non je savais pas mais
je j'adore mauce c'est un copain je
savais il m'a même pas prévenu que ah
non parce que mis des Robins des Bois
voilà on peut le dire ou alors c'est ça
fait partie de la vie privée vous vous
me dites hein si sinon le coupe au
montage non direct CP montage hein non
non mais j'ai pas non c'est que Maurice
ou c'est tous les Robins des bois non
c'est que Maurice Laur c'est que Maurice
parce que des fois mais c'est marrant
parce que vous sortez qu'avec des comics
vous c'est quand même extraordinaire non
il paraît ouais enfin en même temps
c'est il se présente pas comme ça enfin
c'est pas des gens qui qui qui séduisent
forcément avec leur humour euh
ouais enfin quand on s'est rencontré
c'était pas il vous il vous a fait rire
qu non mais c'est pas voyez c'est pas
une carte de visite cherchez pas les com
par exle cherchez pas un plan avec er
RAM ou ruman chevalier lapess non non
non Stéphane Caro mais tu vas me les
sortir non non non ça s'arrêtera à
Stéphane Caro je crois que c'est quand
même ce qu'on peut faire de
ouis est-ce que tu veux faire une minute
de silence pour Stéphane colar c'est un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé tu as vu
alors vous êtes ici ce soir Judit pour
un film qui s'appelle tu vas arriè mais
je te quitte j'avoue que le titre est
assez génial de Philippe Arel sorti le 5
janvier 2005 hein alors le pitch je vais
faire le pit voulez que je fasse le
pachch très bien alors le pitch chaque
année je fais ses pit le pitch c'est
l'histoire d'une comédienne blonde sexy
un peu nunuche qui partage son temps
entre des tournages de sitcom à la con
on peut bien dire et des dîners trop
arosés entre filles et et bref à 30 ans
contrairement à vous elle ne croit plus
au au Prince Charmant voilà ah non elle
y croit encore hein au contra oui elle y
croit enfin elle fait pas grandchose
pour le trouver quand même bah si elle
fait trop de choses même pour le trouver
oui enfin elle se bourre la gueule avec
ses copines la plupart du temps quê
enfin elle couche aussi pas mal hein
elle couche beaucoup ouais elle couche
beaucoup mais avec des mecs sans espoir
parce que le photographe là franchement
c'est pas le genre de mec qu'on épouse
hein non mais le philosophe à la limite
ah le philosophe à un moment elle tombe
sur un philosophe alors on en parlera
parce que c'est intéressant comme c'est
un vieux je me sens concerné évidemment
alors vous êtes parfaite dans le rôle je
voulais vous dire vous êtes une bonne
comédienne je vous le dis comme ça la
télévision et avec Michel laroc et
Marina FO vous êtes dans mon panthéon
des actrices qui sont à la fois jolie et
drôle voilà
ah il y en a pas beaucoup
alors c'est un film assez juste hein sur
la sur la vie d'actrice finalement parce
que par exemple les problèmes d'argent
nous on sait pas ça mais les actrices
évidemment ont des problèmes d'argent
comme tout le monde ce qui fait que
souvent elles acceptent des rôles un peu
moins bien et cetera non ça c'est bien
vu ça dans le film oui ou oui non mais
c'est vrai que la majeure partie des
acteurs galèrent c'est vrai que c'est
pas ce dont on parle et qu'elle fait
partie de cette majeure partie
c'est-à-dire qu'elle accepte des rôles
nul pour pour avoir de l'argent pour
gagner de l'argent pour payer son loyer
et que à force de ne pas travailler elle
bien obligé de de mais en même temps
elle a elle est pas très c'est pas
qu'elle est pas cultivée c'est qu'elle a
pas une éducation forcément qui fait
qu'elle sait comment gérer sa carrière
donc par exemple pour son book elle fait
des photos en culotte c'est pas
forcément évident quoi et bon c'est vrai
qu'à priori les MS en scène vous demande
pas forcément de s'intéresse pas au aux
actrices ou en tout cas à vos sous quand
ils essaient de trouver quelqu'un pour
un rôle oui puis quand elle fait des
castings des fois elle dit oh ben non
vous me faites chier puis elle se casse
quoi elle est pas très politique on
dirait voilà pas du tout politique elle
elle parle sans réfléchir elle met les
pieds dans le plat elle a un côté comme
ça assez maladroite et un peu godiche et
qui la rend drôle forcément puisque
c'est une comédie donc c'est vrai que
c'est un personnage assez jouissif à
regarder tout à fait plus que quelqu'un
qui serait dans la diplomatie dans la
nimesu alors voilà à un moment elle
oublie les mecs de sa génération elle
tombe amoureuse d'un d'un vieux un
philosophe qui lui dédicace un livre ah
bah il est vieux le mec il a au moins
mon âge hein ah ouais et alors après le
le mec lui lui passe un bouquin un
bouquin de philosophie qu'il a écrit qui
est épé comme ça alors il lui dit vous
l'avez lu qu'est-ce qu'elle répond bah
je sais pas elle est un peu mal à l'aise
puis finalement elle finit par lui dire
qu'elle a commencé mais franchement elle
comprend rien quoi puis que ça l'emmerde
en gr voilà et donc du coup elle était
venue pour coucher avec lui elle
espérait vivre une idile et elle pensait
que c'était un peu lidéal ouis et lui
très vexé lui dit que avant de coucher
avec elle faudrait déjà qu'elle commence
par avoir quelque chose dans la tête
donc elle s'en va et il lui dit je te
préviens je te baaserai pas elle
ressonne il lui dit je te préviens je te
baaserai pas elle dit ça m'étonnerait
voilà c'est vrai que ça fait très
comédie anglo-saxon et et et le
personnage féminin est assez surprenant
parce qu'elle est par moment assez bimbo
par un moment assez enfantine et et
c'est un personnage assez surprenant
ouais B vous si vous avez pas ce genre
de problème vous allez fonder une
famille maintenant
avec je par Ch les C et je chante ma Jo
pardessus
mais sérieux non mais quand vous étiez
petit vous fantasmiez sur les clown déjà
non
euh ouais c'est pas faux is j'étais
amoureuse d'Alexis grus ah ouz ben voilà
voilà tout tu vois cette émission tout
finit par s'expliquer vousz pas peur
qu'il soit chauve le petit là
non non parce que Noé les oreilles quand
même non non j'ai peur de rien ah bon
vousz pas vous êtes pas inquiète non Noé
vous lui faites recoller les oreilles le
fils de Danny bon non mais Noé n'a pas
les oreilles décollées 25 points de
suure quand même
quoi vous vous vous langez vous
bibronnez vous j'allette vous allettez
aussi là maintenant c'est
l'heure vous avez lu tous les livres de
Françoise Dolto euh Françoise Dolto mais
Winnie coot surtout ouais Françoise
Dolto c'est un peu inquiétant c'est la
mère de Carlos donc tu dis quand même
quandelle quand elle donne des conseils
sur l'élevage des enfants c'est un peu
je sur l'élevage des enfants je trouve
ça un peu inquiétant Carlos il a grandi
il y a des barbeletis autour ses frères
ses
sœurs euh donc le film s'appelle tu vas
rire mais je te quitte donc on va faire
une interview tu vas rire
mais Judi godrche est-ce qu'on vous a
déjà dit tu vas rire mais attends faut
que je metre mes oreilles
d'abord est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit non
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu vas rire
mais je croyais vraiment que tu
t'appelais le gros
derche mais on me l'a pas tellement fait
à l'école celle avant bah BF qu'est-ce
que tu fais en merde et la première
personne à avoir en fait fait des jeux
de mots avec mon nom c'est de cô quand
j' fait nulle part ailleurs j'avais 17
ans ah ou et c'était God r God mais on
m' jamais à l'école que c'était un god
j'imagine en plus non si quand même je
suis assz jeune dans les écoles
maintenant tu sais je disais les
journaux ah bon ouais ça a changé quand
même ah est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu
vas rire mais je suis pas vraiment
Robain des bois non qu'on vous a déjà
dit tu vas rire mais tu m'excites pas du
tout
non à moi non mais au personnag dans le
film ouais mais à toi jamais à moi non
ouais est-ce qu'on t'a déjà est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu vas rire
mais je préférais que tu te
taises je préférais que tu te taises
ouais euh non jamais dis la
vérité jamais non est-ce qu'on vous a
déjà dit tu vas rire mais c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive
franchement je comprends
pas
ouais
sacré Maurice
[Applaudissements]
ouais est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu
vas rire mais je te trompe avec ta
meilleure amie non mais dans le film ça
arrive aussi ouais mais c'est bien parce
que Elise le personnage du film est pas
une fille rancunière même pas du tout
donc elle redevient copine immédiatement
avec sa meilleure amie et même elle
recouch avec le garçon qui l'a trompé
c'est vrai c'est une fille pleine de
joie de vivre c'est vrai
absolument
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu vas rire
mais j'ai pas d'argent pour payer le
resto là
ouais
ouais est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu
vas rire mais grâce à toi je suis devenu
homo
euh non non on vous a déjà dit tu vas
rire mais je je suis Danny boun je suis
pas Mick mous hein n'importe quoi etce
qu' vous a déjà dit tu vas rire mais je
suis marié
ouais ouais ça vous est arrivé ça ah
ouais ouais h
souvent non mais euh ouais une fois pour
toutes HM est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit
tu vas rien mais je te quitte
ouais j'étais toute petite et ça m'a
marqué h vous êtes bien remise hein et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu